ladies and gentlemen put your hands
together and welcome onstage the
chairman of Vayner X the one and only
Gary Vaynerchuk raise the roof thank you
thank you thank you I love you very much
gosh I'm so excited to be here thank you
for having me
[Applause]
there are so many things that I want to
cover in this time so let's just get
right into it couple things when when
you grow up the way I did and for a lot
of people in this room that don't know
I'll give you the one-minute version
because so much of the energy I'm
feeling here today across the UAE and
specifically at this event and unsocial
with my interactions is I was born in
the former Soviet Union and then I came
to the United States when I was three
years old my father worked every minute
I really didn't spend a lot of time with
him until I was 14 15 when I worked in
the liquor store that he started working
at for $2 an hour as a stock boy and
eventually saved all his money and
bought a store in Springfield New Jersey
I was a product of the 1980s and 1990s
in America which I think when people
look back on will be the golden era of
Education and what college you went to
basically meant who you were going to be
in the world in the face of education
being the only way out in the 80s and
90s especially for an immigrant my
mother created a framework that allowed
me to flourish against my own DNA my
self-awareness who I was which was a DNF
student the worst grades that you could
get in school but also was a child that
on
summer day vacations or when it snowed
or whatever was happening I was always
looking to be an entrepreneur if it
snowed in New Jersey I was ringing
doorbells looking to get money to shovel
snow if it was hot outside I was setting
up a lemonade stand to sell lemonade
from the beginning of my life I was put
in a position
luckily based on where I was and who was
parenting me to actually lean in to my
strengths and the things that I was
passionate about you know it's very
interesting what I'm actually thinking
while I stand here which is here we are
20 years 30 years later from that boy
we're now entrepreneurship gives me the
luxury gives me the honor to come to all
places around the world and people treat
me with admiration and respect and
kindness ironically the explosion of
entrepreneurship and events like this
and movements like this don't excite me
as much as most people think I of course
am a student a product and a humongous
advocate of entrepreneurship however
that is completely secondary to my
passion around self-awareness and
happiness it is my great concern that
the framework the world that has put me
on a pedestal entrepreneurship is going
to blind that some of you in this room
who are actually unbelievably capable to
be a number two a number three a number
seven within an organization but believe
in the hype that the only way to win or
more importantly what's cool now is to
be a founder I encourage every single
person here who has the stomach and the
mindset for entrepreneurship but I
implore you if you take anything from my
keynote today please go home and look
yourself in the mirror
and start having unbelievably honest
conversations with yourself about who
you are versus who you wish you were
today entrepreneurship in 2018-2019
across the world is put on a pedestal I
promise you today I walk into an event
like this
and everybody wants a selfie and I get
treated this way and it's unbelievable
but I promise you as I stand here I am
very mentally prepared for 2027 when the
global economy collapses and I start
getting blamed for teaching or telling
you to do entrepreneurship when your
startup failed for me this is my life
when it wasn't cool now while it's cool
and in a decade when it won't be cool
again I want that for you because when
you do what you were meant to do when
you're able to put two fingers in your
ears and hear nothing not the hate or
the negativity but equally not the
admiration and the accolades you're
playing within yourself you're playing
within yourself my great fear my great
fear around the world is how many people
here are not playing for themselves
they're playing for their parents
they're playing for their friends the
things they buy the things they start
the way they live are predicated on
other people's opinions not themselves
and so I'm not coming here to start with
a buzzkill but I also do not want to be
delusional to the reality of the
situation to build a meaningful company
takes a very long time is very difficult
and more importantly what has happened
in the startup community all those
wonderful startups back there everybody
now is pandering to venture capital or
to raising capital
not to actually building a business
every day thank you it's important and
thank you so much for jumping on that
it's important because let me let me
tell you why in two thousand six seven
eight nine I was taking all of my money
and investing in Tom
and Facebook and Twitter and uber and
all these things that I did very well
with and why over the last four years
I've invested very little very carefully
because there's a disconnect right now
and there's illusions of the reality if
you stand here or sit here today and
there is nothing that you could think
about other than building a business
because the process of building a
business is your happiness not what a
successful business allows you to buy
well then you're a pure-bred
entrepreneur somebody asked me today in
an interview what do I do with my
downtime I told them that I start other
businesses it's all I know it's who I am
it's the same way when I see a teacher
or an artist or anybody when I can see
through their soul that they were meant
to cook or paint or build or whatever it
may be I get such happiness it's the
same reason that people that I went to
school with who make fifty three
thousand dollars a year but I know
they're so happy because it's what they
want they want to be home at 5:00 p.m.
they want to be on multiple sports teams
they want every weekend off they don't
want the pressure let me talk about
pressure real quick can I tell you why I
stand here in this incredible event
where entrepreneurship is being put on
us pedestal something I dreamed of my
whole life
that would eventually be cool and I
start my conversation with heavy levels
of practicality it is because this is
the thing I most fear when the last
regime school had its day you could get
good grades
fake environment very easy to manipulate
you could go work in a company and if
that company fired you or didn't do well
you had somebody to blame you did not
have to take any of the responsibility
or have the scarlet letter of losing
because you were part of a machine the
greatest thing about being a CEO founder
entrepreneur is that when there is
success you get a disproportion
amount of the credit the problem with
entrepreneurship is when it fails you
have nobody to blame one of the things
that I'm most worried about is when you
are a pure bred entrepreneur you don't
care about losing the process is your
religion running the company is your
oxygen when you are not and you're doing
it for everybody else or because it's
cool
when you fail you will have no place to
hide and your loss will be very public
and unavoidable the reason I put so much
pressure on people being self-aware is
if you're a natural number 2 6 13 or 27
the negatives of being a number one are
overwhelming and very difficult to
quantify you have to ask yourself today
that when your business fails are you
okay with the judgment of your family
friends your social media followers and
the entire world and if you are then you
can move on your merry way
but if you are not one of the great
ramifications of this golden era of
entrepreneurship is going to be the
enormous amount of depression and mental
illness when 99 percent of the
businesses fail that concerns me
[Applause]
my friends please don't misunderstand me
I don't stand up here and say I'm an
entrepreneur you're not I say that what
this phenomenon has taught me where I
can go to the most amazing places on
earth and many people know who I am is
that my timing for what I loved worked
out
I take no pride in that I understand
that it's circumstantial but I also know
that this is why I'm so desperate for
you to stick to your guns around your
passion maybe you actually love playing
video games more than starting an app
company when I was growing up playing
video games was a waste of time
today I think we can all agree a
professional eSports superstar for the
next 50 years probably behind proper
football and basketball is going to be
the biggest athlete in our world this is
nothing you could see 7 or 10 years ago
you must you must you owe it to yourself
to make sure that you're building a
company around what you love not because
cryptocurrency is the current fad when
you chase money you lose
always and forever even when you achieve
the money this is how humans are wired
and so we have to have dramatically more
thoughtful conversations around
entrepreneurship startup culture and
what's actually happening in the world
because right now most of the unicorns
are just rhinoceroses in disguise
and please and please don't get it
confused I'm I like every other person
have my selfish wants and needs that
last statement that was selfish d-roc
where are you at I did that right now
the unicorn for rhinoceroses for one
reason I know that 95% of the successful
internet companies that we all put on a
pedestal are so over leveraged against
the reality of their business that when
there is an economic slowdown or
collapse and they can't raise capital
against a ridiculous valuation they will
disappear not because I'm smart it's
because I'm old the one great thing
about being 43 is I've lived through
three collapses a lot of people how many
people here under 32 years old raise
your hands geez the biggest gift and the
biggest vulnerability is that you're 32
right the biggest thing that look
there's so many things that are running
through my mind number one one of the
most fascinating things running through
my mind looking at the Nemea area and
looking at North Africa the Middle East
it's devastating to me how much of the
young talent here thinks they need to go
to America or other places to achieve
their goals when there is so much
opportunity I mean it
and and if you're like me and you love
your family
I wasn't even willing to move to Los
Angeles because I needed to be close to
my mom and dad the thought of going to
another part of the world when the
disproportionate opportunity is doubling
down on your region is fascinating to me
it's a credit to the thing I most care
about which is brand building America's
great achievement in the last 100 years
is using Hollywood to build its brand
please do not get confused there is so
much opportunity within a square mile of
your home let alone the rest of the
region that you do not need to be naive
and think you need to go somewhere to
achieve your goals because I'm jealous
that I'm not under 32 sitting here with
the outlook that I have when you look at
the mobile penetration the percentage of
the youth when you just look at the
sheer opportunity that is in the general
region it's extraordinary
too many people underestimate what's in
front of them and overestimate what's
outside of them I mean it
let's bounce around a little bit I'm
gonna take it to a slightly different
direction because I think it's
unbelievably inherent to so many people
in this room I generally believe and by
the way not everybody should do video
not everybody should be video have
somebody following them around with a
camera if not everybody should do video
however if you're sitting here in the
room front row
last person back there if you are not
producing content for the world on the
Internet
whether that's because you're a
tremendous writer and you can write on
your own blog on medium on LinkedIn on
Facebook pictures because you're
unbelievably visual you could take a
beautiful photo and then write a
wonderful three or four sentences on
your Instagram post if you're stunningly
handsome and charismatic and you can do
video please but if you are great at
talking but uncomfortable in front of a
camera and you have to do audio in
podcast form please understand my
biggest truth here today which is if you
are not sharing your thoughts your
process your journey your progress to
achieving your goals the stories you
want to tell about your startup product
service if you are not communicating to
the world and if you're not thinking
about what's valuable to them not what's
valuable to you when you communicate and
that is a very big point I'll say one
more time if you are not communicating
to the world and when you're
communicating if you're not thinking
about what's valuable to them versus
what you're putting out for yourself you
are basically irrelevant in a 20-19
world as much as it may be difficult for
many in this room if you are not living
through here you are not known this is
the game unfortunately or fortunately I
don't know how you see technology
advances I'll surprise you
I'm not so Pro technology revolutions
I'm just practical
I don't I didn't my friends at 18 years
old me at 18 years old had spent less
than two hours on a computer in my
entire life I am NOT fascinated by
technology at all 3d printing I don't
care if you make 80% of your home's 3d
printed I'm not passionate about that
VRA our blockchain all of it
not really passionate me I'm passionate
about communication and that's where
this happens if you are under estimating
this and when I say under estimating
this if you have not made a significant
commitment to producing content for the
one of seven apps or websites that 80%
of this entire region spends a
disproportionate amount of time
penetrating and listening and consuming
you are becoming vastly vastly
irrelevant so if you leave with anything
from this talk number one please lean
into self awareness there is so much
delusion running through this conference
and this region and this world it's
devastating because it will not end well
number two once you establish that self
awareness
you must speak everybody speaks
differently through pictures words audio
video but you must speak you must speak
because that is absolutely the leverage
that you sit with we're sitting in a
time right now where across this region
there's so much opportunity there's so
much attention in a youtube snapchat
Instagram Facebook Twitter world it's
it's unparalleled there's never been a
time where every person in this room
with nobody in the middle has the
ability to reach anybody they want my
friends actually how many people over 40
in this room raise your hands over 40 I
wish and I'm sure I'm looking at a bunch
of right now there is a complete
misunderstanding of the disproportionate
opportunity that everybody in this room
has all of us who are
four-forty dreams that we entered a
world with this many options we were
stuck in the machine where the two paths
there was no options you were crippled
by options you are crippled by options
which now leads me to the most important
part of this conversation the number one
thing that I think about every day is
why do people live their lives based on
other people's opinions the number one
thing that I really want to have how
many people here under thirty one more
time raising hands man the number one
thing I wish for everybody who just
raised our hand is my ability to spend a
two hour dinner with your parents in
that dinner would be the most
interesting insight especially regions
like this it is fascinating how many
people are dealing with the pressures of
what their parents want them to do
versus what you want to do this blue is
right and the reason your wooing and the
reason that I'm most fascinated is I am
fascinated by watching parents parent
their children in the exact way that
they hated their parents parented them
it's it's remarkable to watch you would
think somebody who was forced to go to
university and become a doctor lawyer
engineer banker all that pain and
anguish that those years created you
would think that they were capable of
not repeating it but the problem is the
great insight of my life is how many
parents parent their children only and
100% based on what other parents think
about their children this is the most
important topic in this region in a
world specifically to this region where
there is so much
opportunity the paradigm shift that is
needed is one on the parenting level to
create the freedom for children to be
able to become happy not check the box
of what they're supposed to do now
before all the thirty year olds clap and
say hell yeah Gary before that there's
one part of the equation for all the
children that are so happy with this
framework if you take your parents money
they're in charge so I love to talk
about you should go do your thing
you should live your life for you I'm
passionate and I believe this that I'd
much rather most of you have two or
three years where you're fighting with
your parents but then have 50 years of
happiness because you're not living with
regret I'm passionate about that the
problem is I've been blown away by how
many kids think they can go start their
own company while their parents pay for
their lifestyle you either live on your
own two feet or you do not
99% of the startups back there will fail
99-97 the amount of people that ever
achieve a business that does a million
dollars in revenue is almost
non-existent yet
we live in a world now where everybody
thinks 50% of people are gonna build a
billion-dollar company optimism is
foundational for entrepreneurship unless
you are blindly optimistic of your idea
you'll never get it off the ground
because everything around you will say
no delusion is the great vulnerability
of startups and entrepreneurs being
practical and realistic and being
optimistic is very feasible
unfortunately it is rare if I could ask
anything how many people here have a
start-up or an entrepreneur raise your
hands if I could ask anything of those
please start converting your business
into something that actually makes money
not is in the need of funding because
when you look at the framework of what's
happening globally we can't survive this
much longer being this globally
over-leveraged and when it falls it
falls hard it fell hard in 2007 and
eight you guys know if hard in 2001 it
falls hard and this is the most over
leveraged we've ever been and so please
if you leave with anything besides
self-awareness please leave with am I
prepared to turn my business in
something that generates profit not is
checking the box for the amount of users
or CAC or LTV or monthly downloads or
all the things that venture capitalists
and funding wants you to do in a game
where those people are playing a very
simple game you have to understand what
investing is about they need to push
every one of their products very hard
because if one gets
it pays for everybody else the problem
is if you're one that got pushed too
hard and didn't build an actual business
you didn't win the fund won because one
of the 50 companies did we need they
call to practicality we need a call to
practicality in our ecosystem because
without it the outcome is always ugly
also when you've had such a long period
of global and I know there's different
markets and I understand but global
prosperity at this level without any
fiscal accountability it's just a matter
of time so my call this morning this
afternoon is a couple of things is this
really the game you want to play because
let me remind you I'm awfully jealous a
lot of my friends who are number three
seven twenty and forty one at Facebook
and uber and all the other companies
that did well number two how practical
is your business have you succumb to the
jargon of startup world where everything
is about users and viewability and CAC
and all these terms that have nothing to
do with are you making more money than
you're losing every month let me tell
you how much talent it takes to lose
money every month consistently zero it
takes zero talent to lose tens if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars every
month while you're building to your exit
it looks good on a chart except the
chart isn't real so what does that lead
me to that leads me to the opportunity
I'm gonna get very practical with you if
you as a person or you as a business are
not buying Instagram story ads in this
region right now right now in this
region UAE
across the Middle East North Africa if
you are not doing that right this second
you are making an enormous mistake
I am the byproduct of buying under
priced ads my whole career my dad's
liquor store
I grew from 30 to 60 million dollars in
five years with no money is because
Google AdWords were five cents a click
and nobody else was buying them
I get ravie the character was because I
was buying ads on Twitter when they were
under priced than YouTube and currently
today right on Instagram stories I'm on
this Arabic Gary Vee account if you want
to go look at any website that shows the
graph of growth this is very meta this
is unbelievable timing this is my
biggest thesis I see a lot of you
shaking your head that means you consume
my content of underpriced attention
buying ads but this is probably the most
excited I've ever been to talk about it
because this account Arabic Gary Vee
literally literally ten days ago had 700
followers it now has 30,000 followers it
has nothing to do with me being in the
region how much 40 mm thank you brother
don't clap clap for yourself when you do
what I did from 700 to 42,000 on one
thing we found on Instagram stories a
piece of content from a quote or two
that I had converted into Arabic bought
across Arabic speaking people across the
world where I am converting followers
for 1.9 cents if you've been in the ad
game I'd be thrilled for 1.9 cent
impressions I would lose my mind for 1.9
cent engagement which would be alike or
passing it on to be able to get to 1.9
cent followers is ludicrous I've never
seen it when my team texted me a week
ago and said weird we have some news
your Arabic page is exploding we found
1.9 cent followers I replied and told
them to spend all of my money on it all
of it you and this is very meta you will
watch my notoriety in this region over
the next nine months go through the
here's why even though I just told all
of you to do it 99% of you will not this
is the story of my life even though I've
just told you 99% of you that the number
one underpriced move in the region
regardless of your business is to buy
Instagram story ads and make a lot of
different content until you find
something that's working for you I am
convinced out of the last 10 years of my
life that 99% of you will not do
anything about it which will allow me to
keep achieving very underpriced
attention if only half of you started to
run meaningful ads on Instagram stories
in this region that price would triple
or quadruple this is the great
fascination of my life even when told
verbatim black and white in-your-face
exactly what to do somehow miraculously
you will not you promise
stand up let's clap it up for him he
will
and now let's clap it up for his shirt
look at that shirt clap it up I like you
[Applause]
it's really fascinating that is what's
happening and that is the great misnomer
that is the great opportunity that is
the great vulnerability we look at the
past and put it on a pedestal and we
look at the current in the future and we
demonize it I'm fascinated by that
we look at technology advances and we
demonize it yet it is the only place
we're going in America a very big trend
especially for affluent parents on the
coasts is to limit the time their
children are on technology I want my
children to only live on technology mmm
thanks mom
the reason I do that is because that's
the world my kids are gonna live in the
horses are not coming back I am
fascinated by people's inability to lean
in to the current like who calls anybody
anymore
how many people here tell the truth by
show of hands get mad when somebody
actually calls them now raise your hand
wait stand up stand up if that's it
stand up please I just want you to stand
up I want to see this visual stand up
I'm gonna give you another second don't
lie stand up if you were actually a
bothered by somebody calling you stand
up tell the truth
just look around everybody look around
this was the most common way we talked
six years ago
please said women that literally if
somebody calls you you look at it and
you're like hello mom why are you
calling me this is because the number
one thing that I trade on is time
friction is the biggest vulnerability
for a lot of people in the internet
business this is why ux/ui design
all this stuff matters so much any
friction you caused is devastating
the second Wi-Fi is a hundredth of a
second slower than you're used to
you are devastated voice is going to be
the next frontier in the same way that
everybody here used to call but now
texts because time is so valuable and
you have it is actually common courtesy
to why you're not calling calling
somebody now without telling them that
you are calling is an invasion on their
time soon voice will replace that if you
really want to be on the cusp of what's
next I genuinely believe that Alexa and
Google home and voice-activated UI is
going to be unbelievably powerful it is
a very boom it's a very very vibrant
place it is and so that's one place to
talk and pay attention to but this all
rounds up to a very simple conversation
which is if you look at the history of
time for Entrepreneurship for the human
race there's all leads to one Road which
is timing timing it's unbelievable how
much timing plays a factor in all of
this so many people back there and in
your heads are playing too much in the
future three years ago all my friends
spent all their money on VR virtual
reality meanwhile I didn't know one
person who spent an hour on virtual
reality a month consistently right so
many people talk about the future timing
of course they are machine learning VR
all this stuff is coming but until you
see it with real people
it's an enormous leap and you're gonna
get your timing wrong right on the same
token the things that I'm passionate
about when I talk about Facebook or
Instagram or snapchat it is only cuz its
current in four years I will sit on
stages like this and I will laugh at
everybody here buying Instagram story
ads because the market will catch
and thus it will become overpriced both
demand for the ads will rise so the
price will go up and you'll stop paying
attention because more ads will show up
this timing this trading this pulse is
the single most important thing once you
understand who you are please start
paying much bigger attention to
consumers behaviors to timing I was
interviewed right before I came up here
and the nice woman said who do you pay
attention to who do you listen to and I
said nobody I don't read books I don't
listen to podcasts all I do is read you
tonight when I'm at the airport on my
way home I am gonna look at the hash tag
of this event and I'm gonna see what you
had to say about the event I'm gonna see
what you had to say about me about the
opening keynote after I consume you if
you want to win in a consumer product
not b2b if you want to win in a consumer
product I highly recommend you start
training yourself to read the consumer
not a thought leaders point of view on
the consumer I would far prefer that you
read every comment about your content
and your spaces content versus watching
my content every day of the week the
reason I have had such a successful
career is because I don't guess I do the
work then I execute then I talk about it
quickly that is my career the fact that
we now live in a world where the
consumers point of view opinions are
being posted immediately in real time is
remarkable do you know many people here
want to build more followers and
influence yet don't reply to the
comments on their posts the sheer
audacity that you want to get bigger
with the world yet you don't have the
time to reply or thank the 13 people
that give a crap about you now
is laughable the quickest way I know
somebody's not on their way to being an
influencer is based on their behavior
with their community publicly please
invest back into the people that invest
in you
[Applause]
I don't know if you heard but the
reality of being a human being according
to modern science is 400 trillion to one
if you follow me for the last couple
years you know I'm obsessed with this
because I can't wrap my head around it
as somebody who likes math as much as
they like art the sheer thought that it
is 400 trillion to 1 to become a human
being is almost difficult for me to
swallow and leads me to my final point
which is mindset if you are sitting here
and you are not driven 100% on gratitude
you are misunderstanding how impossible
it is to even be a human being in the
fact true then the fact that you could
have been a rhinoceros or a tree or a
ladybug
it is so remarkable to me how people
have not quantified the most basic thing
how I sit here I stand right here in
front of you
driven 100% on gratitude I am so
thankful to even get the chance to do
anything let alone what I'm doing I
promise you when you wake up every
morning you don't need a meditation pod
you don't need a book you don't need a
podcast you don't need me if you wake up
and actually say to yourself the
likelihood of me having a life is more
rare than getting struck by lightning 10
times you will put life in perspective
very quickly dwelling or complaining or
crying about what you don't have versus
understanding and leaning into what you
do have is exactly the same way that I
understand that I wish all of you knew
how much better it would be to build a
business here than to move to Silicon
Valley
[Applause]
there's no money there's no accolades
there's no awards there's no amount of
followers that can subsidize actual
happiness actual happiness starts very
internal it starts with how you see the
world it then leads into who are you
listening to and then it goes into your
actions the fact that 85% of this
audience raised their hands and they're
under 30 which makes me know that
they're gonna live three more full lives
based on modern medicine makes me
desperately try to push everybody here
for perspective and patience and right
now everybody's going way too fast wants
everything way too fast and if I could
get you to slow down and pay attention
then I would scratch the itch and I
stand here not only driven by gratitude
but I stand here today my friends driven
by guilt I have enormous I mean this an
enormous level of guilt of how lucky I
was to be born with nothing to grow up
with nothing to have to earn everything
for myself and most of all to have
parents that put me in a position to
listen to myself and nobody else I wish
that on all of you I wish you nothing
but health and happiness and please
please rewind this talk because if you
follow even a percentage of the
blueprint I think something good will
happen thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
I'm just gonna sign this book for him
what's that something
[Applause]